für mich ist es interessant vor allem
wenn man in der Schweiz ist zu sehen die
Stabilität und Funktionalität eines
Staates kann man erkennen an der Bahn in
der Schweiz ist die nicht-minütlich
pünktlich sondern Sekunde auf die
Sekunde genau
man erkennt auch den Zustand
Deutschlands am Zustand der Bahn ich
habe mir nun erlaubt vorgestern mal
wieder Bahn zu fahren und ich habe sie
mir extra aufgeschrieben was ich da
erlebt habe nämlich falsches sage also
sucht nach Erfurt sollte um 10:30 Uhr
gehen ähm war auch alles so keine Ansage
kein gar nichts denn wenn eine Ansage
der Verspätung gekommen wäre hätte man
vorher mit einem anderen so fahren
können also es gab nichts dann gab es
Verspätung in 10 Minuten Rhythmus zum
Schluss 45 Minuten ähm die Ansage lautet
der einmal eine beschädigte Brücke
danach kam Gleisarbeiten danach kam die
Ansage schuld ist einfach rausfahren
dazu
im Zug habe ich dann erfahren durch die
Ansage es sei ein Defekt am Triebwerk
des gesamten Zuges ich bekam dann eine
SMS obwohl man ja schon im Zug saß dass
eine Verspätung zu erwarten sei Grund
eine Reparatur an der weiche also das
ist so die Gesamtdarstellung
so und jetzt ging es aber noch weiter
willkommen im Bistro so ungefähr nach
dem Motto jetzt müssen sich mal ein
bisschen erholen wegen der Verspätung
nach 5 Minuten kommt die Durchsage meine
Damen und Herren es tut mir furchtbar
leid im Bistro gibt es äh technische
Störung mit der
elektro-zufuhr das Bistro ist
geschlossen so jetzt frage ich die Bahn
gott sei Dank hat man ja überall
Verbindungen untersagt mir ein führender
Mensch lieber alleine alles stimmt alles
jede einzelne ist marode die gesamte
Infrastruktur ist letztlich kaputt und
in Leipzig ging es dann weiter da hieß
es dann plötzlich der Zug kann nicht
weiterfahren weil der jetzt insgesamt
kaputt ist
per Ferndiagnose wurde dann das so und
jetzt freue ich mich ja dass er große
Brömer da ist denn
das sind 16 Jahre CSU Verkehrsminister
16 Jahre hat die Union Verantwortung
getragen für die Bahn bis in die Spitze
sogar der Firma hinein wir erleben eine
völlig marode Geschichte die können wir
jetzt nicht bei der Ampel abladen
wir haben über die Energie gesprochen
diese ganze Energiewende ist ja
angefangen bei ihren Truppen da war gar
kein grüner dran beteiligt im Bund eben
im in der Bundesregierung die gab es
noch gar nicht die Bundeswehr das Idee
völlig zugrunde gerichtet worden ist die
arme Frau Lambrecht die hat mir richtig
leid getan die war ja nur noch das
Sahnehäubchen auf dem real existierende
Dilettantismus sie hatten einen
Gutenberg der die
größten Sündenfall mit Beifall der CDU
nämlich die Abschaffung der Wehrpflicht
danach hatten sie so leuchten wie Ursula
von der Leyen die wurden als Belohnung
noch Königin von Europa und ähm Frau AKH
Frau Lambrecht war ja nur noch das Sahne
Häubchen da drauf sie haben im Endeffekt
auch ähm was wir jetzt eben besprochen
haben was Energie angeht uns an Russland
verkauft wieso waren wir denn abhängig
von Russland wir sind abhängig von China
was Argumente angeht ja das ist das was
die Leute vor Ort erleben und das kann
man nicht rausreden ich will nur
verstehen sie dann verstehe ich diesen
peinlichen Populismus von dem
geschätzten Friedrich beherzt nicht der
von kleinen Paschas spricht wer hat denn
die kleinen Paschas im Rahmen der
Grenzöffnung 2015 unkontrolliert hier
reingelassen das waren auch keine grünen
sondern es war die damalige Koalition
und sie hatten als cdu/csu die
Weisungsbefugnis durch das
Bundeskanzleramt und auch die
Fachminister Verteidigung innen und für
die Bahn den Verkehrsminister wenn Sie
heute ihren Wahlkreis fahren weiß nicht
Sauerlandlinie da können sie dann vor
Lüdenscheid abfahren weil nämlich die
Brücke kaputt ist also ich wohne kurz
vor Hamburg aber das wäre der Umweg mehr
zu groß ich war seit vielen Jahren waren
und ich kann Ihre verär über diese
Zuständigkeit man verstehen ja aber du
erzählen sie jetzt nicht dass es alles
an die scheuer oder sonst wer Schuld es
hat massive Investitionen in die
Deutsche Bahn gegeben ob die immer
richtig ausgegeben wurden müssen sie mal
den Vorstand Fragen der Deutschen Bahn
daran daran war ich leider nicht
beteiligt aber da das wäre nämlich
wesentlich besser
ich will nein
keine
Vergangenheitsbewältigung oder was
machen so sondern die Reden nein nein
nein mit dieser Hotze wie sich heute
bestimmte Leute von der Union hinstellen
in diesem deutschen Bewusstsein wir
waren bei allem nicht dabei oder wir
haben von allen nicht gewusst das finde
ich einfach schlimm ähm
und sie haben aber einen Vorteil
deswegen wollen wir geil auf zu reden
die größte Pandemie aller Zeiten dagegen
ist ja Corona eine leichte Grippe ist
die volksdemenz wir haben eine
politische Demenz unter den in der
Bevölkerung die werden treu mit brav
auch in Berlin jetzt wieder alles wählen
über das sie sich an sich aufgeben
sie die Energiewende die Aussetzung
Deutsche Bahn wir haben wir haben uns
abhängig gemacht von von Russland ich
meine die Wahrheit ist folgendes in Nord
Stream 1 hat eine rot-grüne Regierung
geschlossen und Frau Merkel hat
lediglich auf den Knopf gedrückt
darauf antworten
immer nur zu sagen ja das war der und
der und der Herr sondern die Frage ist
wie geht's in die Zukunft weiter noch
mal der Rückspiegel aus Fehlern ja aber
das muss ich aber dann sagen wenn das
immer so so lange eingeworfen wird das
war alles ähm Mama Merkel oder sowas
nein nein nein ich würde sagen nein nein
ist mir egal
cdu/csu ja ja Stream 1 ein Beschluss
einer rot-grünen Regierungschef von von
von gasspeichern von von Sigmar Gabriel
der die Abhängigkeit kann durch North
Stream 2 gar nicht entstanden sein weil
da überhaupt gar kein Gas geflossen ist
zur Bahn habe ich gesagt ich verstehe
ihren Ärger aber da muss dann
möglicherweise im Vorstand was falsch
gelaufen sein zwei Milliarden
Investitionen in die Bahn jedes Jahr
kann man sagen
ja die Bahn ich ich fahre seit vielen
vielen Jahren waren es gibt auch
tatsächlich noch Züge die pünktlich sind
und man kann darüber streiten ob die
ausreichend sind oder nicht ich teile
ihren Ärger und ich bin sehr dafür dass
wir manches verbessern und besser machen
aber das jetzt immer nur irgendwie ein
Verkehrsminister daran schuld ist und
sozusagen die die die die faktische
Organisation durch den Vorstand damit
überhaupt gar keine Rolle spielt können
wir gerne darüber diskutieren
also ich
bin ja erstmal Bahnfahrer und also das
auch so nachvollziehen wie es hier
geschildert wird es funktioniert selten
mal alles irgendwas ist immer kaputt
meistens und und zu spät kommt tun die
Züge und wenn es weniger sechs Minuten
ist gilt das als pünktlich das ist aus
Schweizer Sicht und denkbar da fahren
die Züge auf die Sekunde
ja also das woran liegt das ich muss man
was sagen was sie gar nicht von mir
erwarten würden ich glaube der es war
ein Fehler die Bahn zu privatisieren
ich habe eine Studie
herausgegeben auf Englisch ist das mit
dem englischen Kollegen wo wir also da
ist die Bahn jetzt gerade nicht so gut
ja eben eben wo wir also für alle
europäischen Länder einen Fachmann
gebeten haben da einen Bericht zu
schreiben und zu sagen wo hat denn die
Privatisierung funktioniert und so nicht
und da kam heraus funktioniert hat sie
immer nur da wo anschließend Wettbewerb
geschaffen werden konnte aber bei der
Bahn können Sie keinen sinnvollen
Wettbewerb des Netzes ja nur einmal da
also das ist schwierig da geht das mit
den Zügen auf dem aber dann passt das
natürlich getrennt ja das ist alles Käse
funktioniert überhaupt nicht und wir
haben also eindeutig gesehen dass alle
Länder die die Bahn privatisiert haben
damit auf dem Bauch gefallen sind das
hat also nicht funktioniert man hätte im
Nachhinein ist man immer schlauer das
ist ja auch gut man muss dann nur
draußen lernen und Konsequenzen ziehen
man hätte damals
die staatliche Bahn nicht abschaffen
dürfen ist heute meine Meinung ich war
auch damals nicht so habe ich mich nicht
anders geäußert aber auch war hatte
keine klare Meinung aber nach der Studie
habe ich sie und man hätte den
Beamtenstatus lassen müssen denn der
Beamtenstatus hat ein internes
Anreizsystem für
pflichtgetreues Verhalten ja es gibt
eine Förderung und es gibt auch Strafen
im beamtensystem das ist über
Jahrhunderte gewachsen darauf hätte man
auch mal bauen können das ist durch das
Hauptproblem das aber heute ein Personal
haben
nicht immer entfernt das denn an die das
Pflichtbewusstsein des alten
Beamtenstatus heran aber das sage ich
nicht so Infrastruktur
ich bestreite das ist ein Thema der
infrastrukturform
kaputt
nein das Personal ist nicht mehr das nur
nicht morgen wieder das Beamten
sechs Jahre alt
das ist vielleicht politisch nicht
korrekt das zu sagen aber das ist der
Schluss den ich aus unseren Studien da
ziehe es war also ein historischer
Fehler damals diese allgemeinen
Privatisierungen zu machen man hätte das
genauer unterscheiden müssen Telekom hat
ja funktioniert da haben wir
wettbewerblich Post haben wir auch im
wettbewerbliche zuständig immer wenn
Wettbewerb möglich ist funktioniert das
mit der Privatisierung aber die Bahn ist
nun das musste Beispiel dafür dass es
nicht möglich ist weil es ein großes
Netz ist und die Infrastruktur ein
Gebäck ein Kern einer Industrienation
wenn das nicht funktioniert wie weh tut
das unserer Wirtschaft wie weh tut das
Deutschland wenn das nicht funktioniert
ja das tut uns alles zunehmend weh und
das liegt ja das geht ja weiter also der
öffentliche Sektor funktioniert auch
insgesamt nicht mehr wir sind hier in
Berlin
Geburtsurkunde ein halbes Jahr Liebe
also ich komme aus Bayern ich bin kein
Bayern ich bin Westfalen aber lebe in
Bayern da funktioniert das halt noch was
hier schon lange nicht mehr funktioniert
ein halbes Jahr für die Geburtsurkunde
ja in Bayern
Söder dass er alles funktioniert nicht
alles aber ziemlich viel Vergleich zu
Berlin funktioniert alles
also Wahlen insbesondere ich liebe diese
Stadt ich bin der ewig gewesen schon ich
finde auch toll DDR-Zeit weil wir viele
Verwandten hier hatten er hat meine
Tanten geliebt Berlin liebe ich als
Stadt Arbeit über diese Stadt geht doch
den Bach runter das funktioniert die in
der
infrastrukturierende Straßen geschlossen
für Verkehr ja das muss man auch erstmal
schauen ja das ist ein glücklich
gemeckert funktionierende Straßen fahren
kann ohne ohne irgendwelche im Winter
werden einfach dich gemacht
Entschuldigung
auch gar nichts sondern
in Berlin gibt es lauter Hartz IV
Empfänger tja die sind man ist nicht in
der Lage das System so zu organisieren
dass der Schnee Schnee weggeräumt gibt
es mehr unbegreiflich wie man 10.000
Kofferraum man Fliege mal von Berlin von
dem Flughafen entfernt das ist solch
eine Katastrophe das Vermeiden man muss
das vermeiden
doch das ein Drittel des Flughafens Herr
scheuert und der Dobrindt waren
nicht zur CDC CDU nein nein nein
immer schnell das ist wohl und so weiter
lassen Sie doch das Leben gehen weg das
spielt keine Rolle wer hier
verantwortlich schon eine Rolle
inhaltlich gemacht wo muss man ansetzen
um zu korrigieren das können Sie aber
nur wenn Sie den Fehler benennen aber
Sie müssen sich auch Personen benennen
doch nein das muss man nur im Parteien
gezwängt es geht aber um mehr als
Parteien dezent es geht darum den Laden
wieder in es geht um Kompetenz es geht
darum dass die Parteien inklusive der in
dem Falle in kriminierten Leute sie
wollen doch wohl nicht behaupten dass
Frau von der Leyen und Frau ATK die
Namen Weg das ist nicht aber das ist
überhaupt
Personen am argumentieren
nein das ist nicht in Ordnung
wäre politische dezent Weg Deutschland
ist in einer schwierigen Situation wo
wir den Laden in Ordnung bringen müssen
mit persönlichen Beschuldigungen sie
können nicht sagen er soll die
Personalfrage wecken wenn sie bei der
Bundesbahn das zentrale Problem beim
Personal sehen ja aber nicht Personen
haben keine
Individuen diese Person hat die falsche
Entscheidung getroffen oder sowas sie
haben mit dem ganzen Land ein
Personalproblem sie können nicht mal
einen ganz guten Nachfolger für Gott sei
Dank für eine Fernsehshow die
Personaldecke ist so dünn das Frau 16
machen konnte und jetzt tritt Herr
schalt ihre Nachfolger sie haben mir ein
generelles Personalproblem es hat auch
was damit zu tun dass bei 100.000 Leute
und zwar die qualifizierten jedes Jahr
in Deutschland verlassen ja das ist
richtig hauswandows Problem haben wir
wir haben Personal
ach nein Entschuldigung ist mir zu
billig lieber
Institutes ja wenn ich
Fehler entdecke die in ihrer
Verantwortung sind sage ich doch nicht
da war irgendein Herr der auf Westfalen
stammt und in Bayern lebt und Berlin so
toll findet sondern dann sage ich den
Namen und wer sich in die Öffentlichkeit
wagt und wer die ein solches Amt
übernimmt muss Verantwortung übernehmen
das Problem ist heute so zu übernehmen
gehen
Verantwortung zu tragen und irgendwie
muss derjenige der verantwortlich ist
diese eben auch tragen und ohne Name
natürlich dann muss man den wenn es
nicht funktioniert aber der nächste aber
den gleichen Fehler vielleicht das ist
es ist eine Frage der Stimmungslage in
diesem Land dass wir träumen über eine
Wirklichkeit die man schaffen könnte
durch bloße Wünsche wird irgendwas die
Realität ist eine ganz andere die
wirtschaftliche Realität liegt die muss
stärker berücksachen haben sie wir leben
in einer Demokratie und jeder Politiker
insbesondere jeder Kanzler oder jede
Kanzlerin übernimmt schon dadurch
Verantwortung dass sie sich wie Frau
Merkel dreimal einer Wahl stellt und
wenn Sie eine Mehrheit bekommen für ihre
Politik dann hat sie sowohl beim
Wahlkampf als auch darüber hinaus
Verantwortung übernommen ist sie auch
bestätigt worden weil offensichtlich
manche auch der Meinung waren einmal
über 40 Prozent sie macht den Job gar
nicht so schlecht manche sind und jetzt
können Sie Auffassung sein
kann ja nichts ändern